FANTASTIC BOUNCE BACK GAME.
A SERIES IS NOW TWO GAMES TO ONE
IN FAVOR OF THE NETS.
AS THE BUCKS RIGHT BACK IN IT,
AND WE GO TO LISA.
>> THANK YOU, MIKE, GIANNIS,LY
TELL ME WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH
YOUR MIND WHEN THAT SHOT LEFT
KEVIN DURANT'S HANDS?
>> IT LOOKED GOOD.
BUT THANK GOD IT WENT IN.
P.J. WAS RIGHT THERE THIS.
THAT'S THE SHOT, THAT'S ALL YOU
CAN DO.
TO BE ABLE TO GET THE WIN.
>> TAKE ME LOU THE LAST
DEFENSIVE STAND.
HOW WERE YOU GUYS ABLE TO HOLD
THEM OFF?
>> WE PLAYED TOGETHER AND WANTED
TO MAKE IT AS TOUGH AS POSSIBLE
FOR THEM.
WE KNOW DOWN THE STRETCH, KD IS
GOING TO HAVE THE BALL AND WE
ARE ALL READY FOR IT.
>> YOU GUYS WERE UP BIG EARLY
AND YOU CAME OUT AGGRESSIVELY,
ESPECIALLY YOU, WHAT CHANGED?
>> WATCHING THEM GET THE
BUCKETS.
WE CAME UP PLAYING TOGETHER
AND -- WE STAYED IN THE GAME AND
GOT THE WIN WITH.
>> YOU AND CHRIS KIND OF PUT THE
TEAM ON YOUR BACKS.
DID YOU HAVE ANY KIND OF
CONVERSATION BEFORE THE GAME
ABOUT JUST WHAT YOU GUYS NEEDED
TO DO TO GET THIS ONE?
>> NO, WE HAVE BEEN DOING IT FOR
EIGHT YEARS AND WE KNOW WHAT
TYPE OF GAME IT IS.
WE BOTH CAME OUT READY.
WE ARE ABLE TO COMPETE.
GET IN A SPOT, AND HELP THE TEAM
GET A WIN.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN DO IT 54 A GAME
ALSO.
>> YOU HAD TO HAVE THAT ONE
WITH, IT'S THE SERIES, HOW DO
YOU CARRY IT OVER IN TO GAME
FOUR?
>> WE HAVE TO KEEP PLAYING GOOD
BASKETBALL.
WE HAVE TO ARE TRUST ONE ANOTHER
AND STAY AGGRESSIVE.
KEEP GETTING SHOTS AND MAKE IT
AS TOUGH AS POSSIBLE FOR THEM.
AND HOPEFULLY WE GET OURSELVES
IN A POSITION TO GET A WIN.
AND IF YOU COULD DO THAT, WE ARE
GOING TO BE GOOD.
>> THANKS, GIANNIS,
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE WIN.
>> ALL RIGHT, IT'S HARD TO GET
THE BALL ON THE BASKET.
THAT WAS THE CASE WITH THE
BUCKS, THEY SHOOT 38% FROM THE
FIELD.
19% FROM THREE.
YET SOMEHOW MANAGED TO GET THE
VICTORY AND KEEP THEMSELVES
ALIVE IN THE SERIES.
THEIR DEFENSE OF